après trois ans d'une absence remarquée
rythmée par de nombreuses rumeurs autour
d'une lourde dépression et un mariage à
moitié secret justin bieber est de
retour sur le devant de la scène
notamment en raison de la sortie de son
nouvel album et le canadien de 26 ans a
décidé d'aller plus loin dans la
promotion de ce nouvel opus en ouvrant à
ses fans la porte de son intimité il a
décidé de tout raconter sur les bons et
les moins bons moments de sa vie intime
c'est dans un documentaire en dix
épisodes diffusés sur youtube que le bip
s'est confié et s'il parle de ses débuts
de ses doutes de sa carrière ou encore
de son mariage
il est aussi revenu sur ses problèmes
d'addiction avec la drogue c'est dès
l'âge de 12 ans que le jeune homme a
commencé à consommer du cannabis mais il
a aussi reconnu avoir touché à des
drogues beaucoup plus dure une période
tragique sur laquelle il est revenu sans
complaisance à laissac des stars si
aujourd'hui il prétend ne plus y toucher
le chanteur a bien compris que les
américains adorent la rédemption une
manière d'éloigner les ragots mais aussi
d'assurer une belle promo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça ça reprend un peu le
truc des hyper mal un bois très très fan
de ce garçon parce que aussi que
franchement un gamin qu'on a découvert
comme ça à 14 ans qui est passé par
plein de phases alors ses traits à
l'américaine on est d'accord il ya la
succès story puis ensuite les chèques
enfin avec la chute la descente aux
enfers puis la remontée maintenant avec
la rédemption
bon très bien on connaît le storytelling
par coeur mais je trouve que franchement
pour ces petites frêles épaules il se
débrouille plutôt pas mal il est très
talentueux il est mignon
enfin moi je suis il est très sympa il
est oui mais il est sympa de pas mettre
en cause ses parents parce que moi je me
sens de son père qui est un adolescent
attardé qu'il inventait de fumée
déjeunerait jeudi avec lui
mirror surpris de l'ampleur fait
beaucoup sur gamin il a deux excuses son
père et sa mère déjà au départ puis a
connu son père m'a sur son père a gelé
qui siège à la haye devrait convier des
canards américain non oui alors match
que tu lisais un truc intéressant déjà
la première chose d'intéressant
effectivement quand on est très beau et
qu'on s'habille mal on est style est
alors que cautionner moche et
contaminent mal on a acheté en effet des
frais tu perds mais maintenant je donne
un peu d info tu te dire tu es des
agressions et les deux arrêtes n'en sait
ce qu'est ce qu'un petit avec 40 ans
d'éclipsé une série il fait une série de
12 épisodes sur youtube qui durera un
peu plus alors merci pour moi c'est une
fille d'annie fait une série de 12
épisodes sur youtube qui dira dix
minutes c'est très à la mode maintenant
ils le font tous c'est comme ça qu'ils
sont face caméra effectivement raison
quand il parle il faut que tout dire
parce que vous pourriez tout dire vous
dire passion j'ai tout dire non à vous
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
que malheureusement il sort ses douze
ses douze épisodes juste au moment de
son album sinon effectivement les
drogues l'ecstasy machin oui mais si ces
affaires de son passé avec de la drogue
l'ecstasy les machins un argument
commercial bande-son 10 à la scène pose
un problème c'est juste de la
communication ou la drogue et où ses pas
de communication en mairie c'est juste
marrant ben ali et son album this way
comprend